[Music]
why is there something instead of
nothing well I don't have an answer but
neither did Irwin Schrodinger he did
however point out that the question
itself is astonishing in his book my
view of the world he said this
astonishment and wonder are what we feel
on encountering something that differs
from what we expect but this whole world
is something we encounter only once we
have nothing with which to compare it
and it is impossible to see how we can
approach it with any particular
expectation and yet we are astonished we
are puzzled by what we find yet are
unable to say what we should have to
have found in order not to be surprised
or how the world would have to have been
constructed in order not to constitute a
riddle
[Music]